la unión europea' vive con preocupación
que puede pasar sin rusia decide cortar
el grifo del gas muy especialmente
después de que moscú haya amenazado con
que a partir de ahora todos los pagos y
las compras de gas tengan que ser en
room no es una cuestión que tanto en los
países del g7 como de la unión europea
se han llegado aseguran que los
contratos son muy claros y que seguirán
pagando en euros o en dólares aun así
hay mucha preocupación la comisión
europea está revisando esta cuestión al
respecto aún así varios países han
alertado de que la situación es seria
alemania ya ha activado su plan de
emergencia ante una posible escasez de
gas también países bajos ha pedido a la
población que reduzca también su consumo
en la unión europea es extremadamente
dependiente del gas de rusia
aproximadamente importa un 40% pero aún
así la unión europea ya ha empezado a
activar planes para reducir su
dependencia del gas aproximadamente se
reducirá a unos dos tercios este mismo
año y aún así también quiere tener un
almacenaje de aproximadamente el 80 por
ciento para evitar opciones en el
mercado como las que existen actualmente
principalmente va a confiar en otros
socios como por ejemplo en estados
unidos o en qatar para importar su gas
natural licuado y así dejar de depender
de rusia sin embargo hay países como por
ejemplo polonia que ya quieren ir más
allá a partir de ahora ha decidido que
prohibirá la importación de carbón de
rúsia y a lo largo de este año también
lo hará con el gas y el petróleo
proveniente de este país